hello and welcome to drive at the DW car
show coming up the future of
electromobility
the hyundai ioniq vintage racing around
Germany's Nurburgring plus a performance
Volvo the s60 Polestar
in 2015 poll star became the official
performance division of Volvo Cars the
collaboration with the Swedish automaker
actually goes back to 1996 when pole
star was founded under the name flash
engineering it's been Volvo's
Motorsports partner ever since now it
has designed the most powerful
production vogel's of all time the pole
star branded s60 sedan and the v60
station wagon
back in 2009 Polestar began supplying
tuning and performance accessories for
road going go volts the new dynamic duo
boasts over 50 optimizations resulting
in 270 kilowatts of output and an
equipment package that translates into a
sports car for everyday driving
we checked out the s60 sedan powered by
a souped-up t6 gasoline engine and
all-wheel drive this Polestar production
model comes with plenty of Motorsports
caliber and provides the technical basis
for the current Volvo racing cars and
the FIA World Touring Car Championship
which Volvo returned to last year our
car reviewer Michelle Assenmacher finds
the s60 promising from the outside
thanks to its beefy looks our first
impression on the inside however is the
very opposite the center console with
its maze of buttons and knobs is not too
user-friendly the interior features pole
stars stylish blue stitching among the
other nice features a heated steering
wheel and carbon fiber inlays adorning
the dashboard and center console
the sports seats with their new buck and
nappa leather upholstery provides solid
support for more aggressive driving
styles michelle admits she kind of fell
in love with the steering wheel that
combination of smooth leather and
alcantara gives the wheel far better
grip and a gorgeous feel the suspension
comes with shock absorbers that can be
adjusted and a variety of settings from
super comfortable to super hard ideal
for taking the car out on the racetrack
for example for everyday use the mid
range setting makes the most sense
the s60 also has the power to take on
the steepest of mountains in style
Michelle explains Michelle only found it
right to put the most powerful Volvo
ever through its paces on the Autobahn
as well even at high speeds she feels
that customary Volvo safety so for now
we have the mid-sized s and v60 editions
but Volvo intends to establish Polestar
as a performance brand for other
segments as well it will be interesting
to see which models bear the pole star
badge in the future
I know the show has to hand it to the
s60 Polestar on one front it's a lot of
fun off the highway as well good
acceleration of these curvy country
roads and a tight turning circle testify
to the cars agility a pleasure to drive
all in all the Volvo s60 Polestar is a
sporty ride that's really fun to drive
ultras the net Sykes's fought legend
tells me a holistic fifth whatever
titled prices for the s60 Polestar in
germany started 68,000 euros
before day before the hyundai ioniq hits
the streets in october explains Iman oh
well Schaffer you can get a sneak
preview at the generation ionic tour
which kicks off at Frankfurt Sean once
so I leave after that the roadshow will
be moving on to Oslo Amsterdam and Milan
the purpose-built pavilion is in the
shape of the Q featured in the new cars
name
inside Auto fans can marvel at an array
of fascinating exhibits and that
includes the engineering powering the
ionic the hyundai ioniq was developed
for three alternative drive concepts
hybrid plug-in hybrid and probably the
most interesting the all-electric and a
real treat here says he mono is being
able to take a look at the inner
workings you can feast your eyes on the
high voltage battery and how all the
components are interlinked
then there's the transmission and the
electric motor itself and this is how
the complete package looks a sleek
design that obviously needs no radiator
grille thereby enhancing the
aerodynamics this car enthusiast likes
the look and the little details Hyundai
has had a lot of people asking for a
test drive from both potential buyers
and other drivers who are simply curious
all you need is a valid driver's license
it's an amazing experience all you hear
are the tires the way it takes off from
the traffic lights with all that torque
really is extraordinary
you don't get that with a regular color
visitors from around the world have come
to Frankfurt skyline Plaza to inspect
Hyundai's electric hatch it's a very
very comfortable Drive yeah I mean sky
is really quiet and you have the feeling
that it get into the speed very quickly
everyone agrees that the hyundai ioniq
is a silent delight
really nice car very very silent smooth
to handle and I still want to see a bit
more in regards to like its compartment
and the grades that are in alpha the
hatch has 350 liters of cargo space hold
down the rear seats and that figure
rises to over 1400 liters the case under
the cargo net contains the charger cable
that can be plugged into any regular
outlet alternatively and far faster you
can use a charging station of course
then filling up to an 80 percent charge
takes only 23 minutes
the hyundai ioniq comes with a choice of
equipment levels all include a
comprehensive package of standard
features from heated side mirrors to a
hill start assist and rear parking
sensors
the interior has a number of stowage
compartments and the front cabin has a
driver friendly layout fashion would top
class workmanship when you start up the
ioniq a display lights up relaying a
variety of stats such as charge status
and range remaining the first version to
be launched will be the hybrid it is
powered by a combination of a 1.6 liter
direct-injection gasoline unit with 77
kilowatts and an electric motor with 32
kilowatts it will be followed in
November by the ionic electro with 88
kilowatts of power and a range of up to
280 kilometers the price tag in Germany
just over 33,000 euros my first time i
drive an electric car and i'm convinced
that it says so is the way for the
future it was also this lady's maiden
voyage in an electric car and she loved
it too one thing that I saw educational
of me that's a point of time and there's
another reason for drivers to go
electric
in the German government has launched a
1.2 billion euro program to subsidize up
to 400,000 electric car purchases
through 2020 a paltry 3,000 applications
have been submitted to date but perhaps
hyundai ioniq will manage to give that
figure a big boost car buyers get a
financial incentive of up to four
thousand euros and as another bonus a
good conscience as regards the
environment Mercedes has unveiled a
prototype for the delivery van of the
future inside the vision van is a
shelving system that automatically sorts
parcels for subsequent delivery by hand
the van is also fitted with a launch pad
and two drones that can autonomously fly
packages to addresses within a range of
10 kilometres mercedes says the vehicle
will make deliveries faster and more
efficient Howdy's new TT RS Kupe boasts
294 kilowatts of output the kupe makes
the dash to 100 km/h in just 3.7 seconds
the top speed can be optionally raised
from 250 to 280 km/h the new five
cylinder aluminium engine generates 480
Newton meters of torque applied to front
and rear wheels the TT RS Kupe will set
you back sixty six thousand four hundred
euros
for over a half a century the caravan
salon in Dusseldorf has been the perfect
place to check out all the latest trends
in camping the leading trade fair for
motorhomes and caravans
through a record 200,000 visitors this
year young people in particular seem to
have rediscovered the joys of camping
head of Germany's Caravan Industry
Association says a lot of young families
came and a considerable number but a new
Caravan the increase in sales was way
above the association's own expectations
Novato
this year's caravan salon had more
exhibition space than ever offering a
dizzying array of options from compact
and practical camper vans to the heights
of luxury visitors to the trade fair
would be well-advised to make up their
minds beforehand about what it is
they're looking for
whether it's a romantic holiday for two
or something with space for the whole
family check out your finances too if
you know what you want the choice is
less overwhelming this man's looking
specifically for an affordable campervan
based on a box van but he wants to try
some out first so he's going to inquire
about options for renting vehicles the
classic VW Transporter is still one of
the leading camper vans despite its
relatively high price the California
version is the most popular choice and
retains its value on the second-hand
market the basic level Beach trim comes
with a bed but no kitchen prices in
Germany start at 42,000 euros the Carmen
Calibri $4.99 from Renault is a shade
cheaper at 41,000 euros it comes with a
kitchen and refrigerator the basic
version has an 88 kilowatt engine and
practical features like cruise control
the new personal campster from suit when
is only a prototype at this stage but
due to go on sale next year the focus
here is on flexibility the kitchen is
included but can be removed if desired
turning the campervan and to a normal
van with seven seats prices for the 70
kilowatt basic version started
thirty-eight thousand euros
or you could go for this more Spartan
alternative and save another 10,000
euros it includes bed auxilary heating
cooler box cruise control rear view
camera and hands-free communication the
trade fair price for this Alpine camper
based on the Nissan nv200
was just 28,000 euros but there's a yet
more basic version still the kuku
camping box it comes in various sizes
and can fit into practically any box
type van turning it instantaneously into
a mini camper van at the other end of
the spectrum the 12-meter long Vario
perfect offers space and luxury galore
an 8 kilowatt diesel generator provides
electricity and there's 600 litres of
fresh water on board the whole thing
will set you back about 1.2 million
euros and that doesn't include the
Mercedes 300sl roadster in the rear
garage
space and luxury is one thing but a
growing number of customers also want
undiminished connectivity on holiday as
next this man says his next camper van
needs to have Wi-Fi and solar panels so
that he can work that way the children
can enjoy the whole summer holiday
traveling and not notice if their
parents work for two or three hours a
day Daniel Feeney all right if you have
six hundred eighty thousand euros to
spare you might want to go for the
ultimate experience of freedom with the
action 'mobile here you can go off-road
or wherever you want it comes with a
three hundred ninety seven kilowatt
engine and a six hundred litre diesel
tank so you can tour through the wilds
for as long as you want without running
out of fuel or having to forego any of
those creature comforts action mobile
CEO Stefan vet says the RV offers
everything you could find at home
including an induction cooktop a washing
machine and an electric oven all the
appliances are good quality makes it has
a huge battery capacity which you could
live from for days without necessarily
having to drive in Malta leaving on
energy efficiency is key for undertaking
lengthy off road trips the Bliss is
completely self-sufficient thanks to the
solar panels on the roof with a storage
capacity of 400 amp hours you could
experience a three-day solar eclipse and
still not have to worry about using the
oven or air-conditioning
in the fall of last year mercedes-benz
brought out its revamped ML model with
distinctive daytime running headlights
and a modified radiator grille and a new
name on the rear it's now called the GL
II our car tester montes says that
Mercedes has renamed its entire SUV
range to include a G at the front the G
stands for gallon Devon German for an
off-road vehicle so the GL E is an SUV
version of the e-class nameless does
Linda van canto sua a closet our test
car the g le 350 d has a 3 liter
6-cylinder engine offering 190 kilowatts
of power according to mercedes the goe
uses just 6.6 liters of fuel per 100
kilometers the luxury SUV can sprint
from 0 to 100 in 7.1 seconds
mother says the car stays nicely under
control even when you drive fast around
corners but unfortunately it doesn't
always feel that way at the wheel he
would prefer the steering to be more
direct even if he switches to the sport
drive mode he still has the feeling of
the steering and the wheels are barely
connected the end copied from line under
the engine the GLA weighs just under two
point two tons and you can tell the
handling is not too sporty but the high
seating position is ideal for driving
off-road montes really likes the
autonomous cruise control when activated
it automatically controls your distance
to the car in front of course but what
do you do on the highway when you're in
the middle lane and the outside lane is
moving slower than you are normally on
other cars you would still automatically
move up to the car in front but with
this car it also regulates the distance
to vehicles traveling in the lane to the
left so that you're not at the risk of
overtaking on the inside and equally
ahead common Mercedes has been pretty
conservative with the exterior large air
intakes wraparound headlamps and
striking LED daytime running lights are
the limit of the cosmetic changes the
rear sports Mercedes typical nighttime
LED lights
inside you immediately notice the large
infotainment screen position over the
middle console between two air vents
the driver's seat is comfortable and the
raised position provides a good overview
of the road the controls are also
uncluttered and easy to use
and Montes does find the controls on the
infotainment system less-than-ideal
however it has a dial here which is
normal enough but above that there's a
touchpad and unfortunately it's just in
a position where you tend to lay your
hand on it while waiting at a traffic
light or stuck in traffic and end up
entering things on the multimedia
interface that you never intended people
don't necessarily need a GS as montes
but it's definitely a very luxurious way
to travel and you can easily hook it up
to a trailer or a big Caravan and take
the whole family on holiday the trunk
offers sufficient space the seats are
very comfortable both in the front and
the rear for foreigners over Hinton as
they're good and so his overall
impression is actually quite positive
aside from less than sporty handling
which is not to his taste
NIC - mocking splished vitalist
our expert Reinhold Dyson over says
vintage car races like the old-timer
Grand Prix at the nürburgring attract
thousands they come not just to look at
the old cars but to experience classic
motorsport and watch Daredevils in their
driving machines race cars from various
classes can relive their glory days
Formula three vehicles dating from 1964
to 1980 as well as touring cars from
different series are all on hand
vehicles from each category get half an
hour on the track to strut their stuff
drivers push the cars to their limits in
spite of their age
Odie's my note says retro is in not just
in music but for cars too more and more
automakers are recognizing this and
focusing on their products tradition
especially sports car makers like
Porsche and Alfa Romeo Porsche has
countless stories to tell as 70% of all
Porsches ever built are still drivable
today when it comes to classic sports
cars real beauty never fades and Porsche
is keen to help owners keep their older
models looking good its Porsche classic
Department offers original replacement
parts for vehicles from years past
to mark the 40th anniversary of Porsches
transaxle technology over 100 privately
owned cars are taking part in a parade
but before the convoy sets off drivers
gather for a photo leading the way is
this 924 GTP sports car with legendary
racecar driver Derek bell at the wheel
they'll have a feeling because it's what
I raced at Lava in 1980 so to sort of
get back in the car again after what
whatever that is 35 years is pretty
special
but it felt just the same as I remember
it but of course in those days we just
went for it there was nobody in front so
you just went flat out and they were
it's so easy to drive then they're off
though here they're not allowed to
overtake one another this is a parade
just for show not a race all manner of
Porsches zoom around the circuit but
they do have one thing in common all
feature a front engine and rear-wheel
drive
Jaguar has set up what looks like a
giant car lot at the Grand Prix here
current models like the f-type sports
car the XF sedan and Jags new
all-electric formula e race car stand
alongside vintage treasures like this
1966 XJ 13 now lovingly restored this
prototype was totalled back in 1971 when
a wheel came off during the filming of a
promotional video Norman doiis was
Jaguars chief card tester for 33 years
he says the car could have had a great
career in motorsport it would have been
a good winner for LeMond one thing you
gon do is test the drivers you can't do
that
but if it have been Jim correct me would
have won I think whether it's 5 liter 12
cylinder engine and an output of 369
kilowatts the XJ 13 certainly had the
prerequisites but Jaguar abandoned the
project in 1967 instead the C D and E
type brought the British company acclaim
on the racing circuit and those models
got to take to the track once again
for the Grand Prix at the nürburgring
other manufacturers such as Ferrari
Maserati and Alfa Romeo are also here
showing off both old and new models
Pinal says events like this provide the
perfect platform to present vintage
vehicles and an opportunity to introduce
supercars
that's what McLaren is doing - taking
the opportunity to show off its latest
supercars like this six 50s
and next time on drive it a classic
updated the new e-class station wagon
from Mercedes and small and sporty with
a soft top the Mazda mx-5